Of course we do need to play basic sound clips. For Grits though we have robots
moving around a 2D world making noise and causing mayhem. It doesn't make a lot
of sense for a sound on the opposite side of the game map from the player to be
just as loud as the one right next to them. So it's not quite enough for a game
like Grits/g. What we need, is to also add the ability to adjust the volume
based on the game state. And that solves the problem I just mentioned. With web
audio, you can adjust the volume of sounds based on how far that are from a
play position on the screen.
[SOUND].
This provides a much more realistic sound environment than you could achieve
with, for example, the audio element. You can think of a lot more situations
where it could be cool to have more involved sound effects. Maybe you want to
apply an echo effect based on how sound
[SOUND]
reflects over that walls. Or apply a Doppler effect
based on the velocity of a player or a projector. This can quickly get pretty
involved. In Grits we simplify this and go for basic volume changes. The point
is you need to think about what level of sound complexity is right for your
game and your team.